bonsoir bienvenue très heureuse de vous
retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce soir
Patrick Klugman l'avocat des familles
d'otage franco-israélien détenu par le
Hamas avec lui nous reviendrons bien sûr
sur l'accord de libération des femmes et
des enfants 13 d'entre eux seront
libérés dès demain après-midi sur 50 au
total dans les qu prochains jours attend
évidemment un soutenable pour les
familles des otages français qui
redoutent que leurs proches ne soient
pas sur la liste notre grand débat ce
soir réveillez-vous l'injonction
présidentielle au chef d'entreprise
n'est pas passé inaperçu face au chômage
qui remonte le président intime les
patrons d'embaucher davantage et pour y
parvenir Bruno Le Maire promet un tour
de vis sur l'assurance chômage des
senéniors est-ce la bonne solution nous
en débattons dans un tout petit instant
sur ce plateau avec mes invités enfin
nous affranchis ce soir le parti prix
politique de yalgose le billet philo de
Pierre-Henri tavoyot et puis Bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'assemblée sera signée par Marco Pomier
ça vous regarde c'est parti vous avez le
programme on y
[Musique]
va pas question donc de s'endormir voilà
donc les Français prévenus les réformes
les plus lououreuses ne sont pas
derrière nous le plein emploi pourtant
reste l'objectif même si le chômage
repart à la hausse alors comment y
parvenir et qui doit faire le gros d
efffforts d'ici la fin du quinquena
bonsoir Paul midi bonsoir merci d'être
là vous êtes député renaissance de
lesson et vous débattez ce soir avec
Aurélie trouvet bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être là député la France insoumise de
scène Saint-Denis bonsoir François
gerérolf bonsoir bienvenue économiste à
l' FCE et bonsoir Michel Picon bonsoir
ravi de vous accueillir vous êtes le
vice-président de l'UDP l'Union des
entreprises de proximité TPE PME artisan
commerçant profession libérale je vous
donne la parole madame messieurs dans
quelques instants on va d'abord planter
le décor comme chaque soir pourquoi
diable le président intime les patrons
de se réveiller on voit cela avec
Stéphan Blakowski dans son chrono tout
de
suite et bonsoir mon cher
Stéphane bonsoir Miriam bonsoir toutes
et tous alors le chômage repart à la
hausse bah d'abord félicitations Mariam
franchement le fait d'organiser un débat
sur la hausse du tout de chômage c'est
quand même très courageux parce que je
sais pas si vous le savez ah bon non
regardez c'est vraiment le sujet dont
les Français n'ont absolument aucun
intérêt regardez c'est le R de
préoccupation et ça arrive en dernière
position c'est pas ce qui bête le chage
le chômage
je vous rassure quand même on n'est pas
les seuls le monde la semaine dernière
faisait ça une sur la remontée du
chômage rien de très étonnant les
journalistes parlent plus plus
volontiers des trains en retard que des
trains qui arrivent à l'heure évidemment
mais du coup regardez où on en est après
sur la hausse du chômage voilà il y a eu
deux trimestres de hausse de suite donc
on en est à 7,4 % donc ça remonte un peu
mais c'est vrai que si on prend la
courbe depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
d'Emmanuel Macron il y a quand même eu
une net baisse pe-êre pour ça d'ailleurs
que les Français sont moins préoccupés
par le sujet en revanche à l'Élysée on
est toujours préoccupé par la question
du chômage puisque vous le savez le
président a fixé cet objectif du plein
emploi en 2027 c'estàdire un taux de
chômage en dessous de 5 %. résultat
comme on n'y est pas et bien B c'était
hier ou avant-hier est Lisée il a poussé
un petit coup de gueule devant des
entrepreneurs on l'écoute
réveillez-vous je vous le dis en toute
sincérité réveillez-vous on est à 7 % de
taux de chômage et donc oui nous allons
devoir redoubler de courage et d'énergie
en matière de travail d'emploi nous n'y
sommes pas
la motivation est là mais le problème
c'est que quand même la conjjecture
internationale n'est pas fameuse en ce
moment et d'ailleurs les experts sont
assez pessimistes sur la question de
l'emploi voyez que la Banque de France
prévoit 7,8 % de taux de chômage en 2025
encore plus pessimiste l'OFCE parle de
7,9 % carrément l'année prochaine donc
de toute façon dans un cas comme dans
l'autre on est voyez très largement
au-dessus des 5 % visés donc que faire
évidemment vous savez que brunult le
maire est en première ligne sur ce
dossier
et il a fixé trois priorités pour
atteindre cet objectif du plein emploi
donc le premier c'est construire des
logements notamment dans les régions qui
recrutent où les jeunes actifs ont du
mal à se loger un plan a été lancé au
début de à la rentrée autre priorité la
formation donc ça peut-être que ça fait
référence aussi à cette réforme des
lycées professionnels qui a lancé au
mois de mai le président Macron mais
c'est surtout la troisème priorité de
Bruno Le Maire qui risque de faire débat
puisque voyez-vous selon lui c'est notre
modèle social qui est trop généreux et
c'est ça qui nous empêche d'atteindre
l'objectif des 5 % d'ailleurs ce matin
il avait fait une il a fait une
proposition son France Info proposant de
réduire la durée d'indemnisation des
plus de 55 ans qui aujourd'hui ont droit
à 27 mois d'indemnisation et de le faire
passer à 18 mois comme pour les moins de
55 ans on l'écoute je ne vois aucune
raison pour qu'il y ait une durée
d'indemnisation plus longue de ceux qui
ont plus de 55 ans par rapport aux
autres parce que dans le fond c'est une
hiypocrisie totale c'est une façon de
mettre à la retraite de manière
anticipée les plus de 55 ans moi je
crois exactement le contraire je pense
qu'on a besoin de leur talent de leur
savoir-faire et de leur expérience et
voilà vous avez bien entendu si Bruno Le
Maire veut réduire la durée
d'indemnisation des seniors c'est pour
leur bien pour qu'ils travaillent plus
longtemps alors moi je sais pas je me
souviens de la réforme des retraites et
la perspective de travailler pu
longtemps n'avit pas l'air d'enchanter
les Français bon est-ce que c'est
efficace ça au moins on pourra en
débattre merci beaucoup Stéphane pour ce
pour ce billet comme chaque soir très
très complet je vais commencer avec
l'économiste que vous êtes parce qu'on a
vu l'OFCE qui n'est pas très pessimiste
optimiste pardonnez-moi sur sur l'emploi
vous l'analysez déjà comment cette
hausse à quoi est-elle d principalement
François girolf et est-elle durable
alors la hausse du taux de chômage est
prévue par l' FCE à 7,9 % à la fin de
l'année prochaine donc il y a beaucoup
d'incertitude hein dans ces prévisions
faut pas faut pas non plus les prendre
trop au sérieux mais c'est vrai qu' il y
a la forme il y a la réforme des
retraites qui qui est importante parce
qu'effectivement va falloir créer des
emplois plus d'emplois que d'habitude on
va dire pour maintenir ne ser que le
taux de chômage ensuite la productivité
est en baisse et donc il y a un petit
peu une question depuis le début de
cette crise pourquoi l'emploi est-il
aussi dynamique pourquoi se porte-il si
bien alors qu'en fait la croissance est
pas si bonne que ça étant donné la
croissance des emplois et donc
l'hypothèse de l' FCE c'est que on va
avoir un rattrapage entre les deux dans
le sens de l'emploi qui va diminuer pour
rattraper la croissance et non pas
l'inverse donc la promesse d'arriver à 5
% en 2027 et ben oui et d'autant plus
donc ça va être difficile de revenir à 5
% en 2027 d'autant plus que devant nous
on a quand même des difficultés
budgétaires à savoir la France est
censée revenir à 3 % elle s'est engagée
par la loi de programmation de de
finances publiques et on voit pas très
bien pour le moment où les économies
vont effectivement pouvoir être faites
et donc si on croit ce plan de de de
pluriannuel de finances publiques les
difficultés sont en train d'arriver et
puis pour finir la hausse des taux de la
Banque centrale européenne fait que la
construction est dans une difficulté
très très grande et donc c'est difficile
pour les constructeurs de créer des
logements là où il y a les emplois dans
une perspective de réindustrialisation
et puis en plus le secteur de la
construction en lui-même fait qu'il y a
une très forte hausse du chômage dans le
secteur de la construction donc donc les
indicateurs sont en rouge et les planèes
ne sont
pas qui qui n'est pas dû au au
gouvernement pour la plupart mais c'est
vrai que la France par exemple pourrait
euh pousser peut-être plus pour que la
Banque centrale européenne aille un
petit peu moins loin dans la hausse des
taux euh à mon avis ça ça serait ça ça
serait quelque chose d'utile on va y
revenir d'ailleurs hein sur ce levier
monétaire sur cette question des taux
Paul mid dit paris perdu pas du tout
pourquoi alors attendez je vous remets
quand même le grave c'est la la promesse
serura tenue vous pensez il faut qu'on
la tienne rest 3 ans euh 2017 début du
quinquen presse de 10 % du chômage on en
est à 7 % c'est historique le chômage
n'a jamais été aussi bas plus haut
peut-être voilà très bien très bien on
la voit on la VO VO c'est pas mal c'est
important 10 % là on voit voilà ça
baisse hein je crois on est à 7 %
aujourd'hui c'est le plus bas depuis 40
ans depuis que je suis né moi j'ai 40
ans cette année je suis né dans un pays
où c'était le chômage de masse depuis le
début de ma vie donc on na jamais été
aussi bas l'objectif c'est d'aller à 5 %
c'est là sur le sur le graphe d'ici
2027 et donc on va tout faire pour y
arriver mais le président a raison
pourquoi il dit révez c'est quoi ce
réveillez-vous c'est un gros coup de
pression sur les patrons non pas
exactement je vais le je vais
l'expliquer parce que moi j'étais face
au président il y a de jours quand il a
dit ça là d'abord où il a raison c'est
que pour passer de 10 % à 7 % de sommage
ça s'est pas fait tout seul ça fait
parce qu'on a réformé le pays on a remis
des conditions favorables à l'économie
et à la création d'emploi c'est
notamment toutes les baisses d'impôts
massifes qu'on a fait baisse de l'impôt
sur les sociétés mise en place de la
flat taxe baisse très forte des impôts
de production suppression de la CVAE et
cetera on a remis ça dans le bon sens on
a fait des réformes structurelles comme
la réforme de l'assurance chômage donc
ça c'est c'est pas venu tout seul
qu'est-ce que dit le
président de 7 % à 5 % non on va
continuer à réformer ça ne se fera pas
tout seul et encore moins dans un
environnement économique mondial qui est
averse donc vous êtes d'accord avec Bron
le mer avant de venir sur le chômage et
l'indemnisation précisément il y a
quelque chose qui cloche encore dans
notre modèle social malgré vos réformes
structurelles c'est ce qu'il dit le
ministre on est trop généreux alors je
vais faire deux précisions d'abord je
vrais préciser les propos du président
parce que c'était pas un coup de gueule
contre les patrons il faut bien
reprendre ses propos c'était un coup de
gueule contre tous ceux opposition
partenaires sociaux certains partenaires
sociaux qui pensent que ça pourrait se
faire en un coup de baguette magique et
sans réformer donc ça n'était pas un
coup de gueule contre les patrons qui
étaient d'ailleurs des patrons de PME
qui étaient face à lui qui
embauche tous ceux qui croient qu'on
peut le faire S passer pour les Français
je pense aux retraites à l'assurance
chômage aux ordonnances travail ça va
continuer il faut qu'on continue à des
efforts pour tout le monde y compris les
salariés mais attendez c'est pas les
efforts qu'il faut mettre en avant c'est
qu'on va continuer à transformer notre
système pour qu'on tue le chômage tuer
le chômage et aller au plein emploi
c'est bon pour nos compatriotes a rit lu
trouver c'est vrai quand on écoute Bruno
Lemer avant de venir en détail sur la
question du du chômage des seniors il
dit il faut plus de logement surtout là
là où les salariés ont leur travail il y
a un problème réel de de distance
géographique plus de formation aussi
parce qu'il y a une inadéquation on
cherche des couvreurs on cherche des
soudeurs après la tempête et il y en a
pas dans beaucoup d'endroits 500000
emplois non pourvu on va pas faire venir
500000 immigrés c'est énorme donc c'est
pour les français pour les salariés donc
est-ce qu'il faut pas entendre ça est-ce
que vous pouvez acquesser à ça formation
formation profession qualifiant au lycée
et logement déjà d'abord c'est pas
500000 emplois vacan d'abord d'après
l'INC c'est 367000
vacan voilà c'est 367000 emplois vacants
pour combien de chômeurs parce que vous
nous montrez les chiffres utilisés par
l'INC je peux vous montrer aussi les
chiffres utilisés par la Dares et Paul
emploi c'estàdire le nombre d'inscrits à
P emploi on est à 5,3 millions de
chômeurs inscrits à P emplois pour
367000 emplois vacan ça fait donc 14
chômeurs pour un emploi disponible donc
tout ce discours du gouvernement qui
vise à dire depuis le début en fait les
chômeurs ils l'ont bien choisi et de les
culpabiliser c'est le discours
d'Emmanuel du président Macron quand il
dit mais traversez la rue vous trouverez
du boulot ce qui est tout à fait faux
puisque on voit bien qu'il y a 14
chômeurs pour un emploi disponible tout
ce discours amène à culpabiliser les
chômeurs et il est faux il est faux en
vérité on a un problème aujourd'hui
d'emploi disponible pour les 5,3
millions de chôeurs et donc moi j'ai
envie de dire plutôt au président Macron
à lui réveillez-vous parce que en vérité
on a une économie qui est en berne du
fait de choix politique d'abord c'est
vrai vous l'avez dit la politique
monétaire certes qui est décidé euh dans
la zone euro mais on n' pas vu le
gouvernement taper du point sur la table
vis-à-vis de la flambée des taux
d'intérêts qui est effectivement une
catastrophe pour l'économie mais surtout
c'est accompagné d'une politique
budgétaire d'austérité qui est tout à
fait néfaste et ça c'est le combo
vraiment désastreux contraire contement
à d'autres pays qui ont pas du tout les
mêmes résultats les États-Unis par
exemple et bien ont une politique
budgétaire ambitieuse vraiment offensive
avec c'est vrai une relance budgétaire
avec une hausse des revenus des classes
moyennes et précaires tout l'inverse de
la France en France on a un taux de
croissance en berne 0,8 % l'année
prochaine on est à 0,9 là on a des gain
de productivité François Guerolf l'a dit
qui sont à zéro quasiment on a un
chômage qui repart donc c'est la relance
par la demande on connaît on connaît
très bien ce levier économique que que
vous prenez on va on va en discuter mais
je voudrais quand même après qu'on
arrive sur le chômage parce que c'est
quand même ça qui pourrait être en
discussion au Parlement si une nouvelle
décision d'ailleurs c'est pas le
Parlement c'est l'Unedic qui décide ça
c'est les partenaires sociaux c'est à ce
stade une proposition du ministre le
patron que vous êtes Michel Picon
comment il l'a vécu cette cette demande
à secouer les puces pour reprendre ça
c'est pas le Président c'est c'est BR le
ma on est dans la dans la traditiontion
des punchlin il faut avoir des mots
forts pour créer du buzz et créer du
débat et pourtant le président n'a pas
besoin lui de créer du buzz il est
suffisamment connu apprécié ou pas par
par les Français donc moi sur cette
injonction réveillez-vous je la je la je
la modère dans dans une expression bon
les entreprises elles sont parfaitement
réveillées et d'ailleurs si nous sommes
passés de 9 à 7 points c'est pas pardon
de de de de de vous rectifier un petit
peu c'est pas l'action dans la réforme
des retraites c'est aussi la création
d'emploi et l'énergie que les
entreprises ont mis à créer de l'emploi
conquérir des marchés se développer
c'est ça qui crée de l'emploi et les
injonctions les incantations ne feront
pas recruter des salariés dans une
entreprise quand votre carnet de
commande est vide or et je partage pas
complètement madame la députée votre
votre position parce que traverser la
rue bon là aussi c'était une autre une
autre forme de punchline mais c'est vrai
que des restaurateurs partout en France
ferment le midi parce qu'ils n'ont pas
assez de collaborateurs pour travailler
c'est vrai que des vétérinaires alors
dit la restauration c'est dur c'est un
métier compliqué oui c'est vrai mais qui
donne aussi beaucoup de satisfaction des
vétérinaires et de vétérinaires ils en
cherche partout des comptables cherchent
des collaborateurs partout alors c'est
un problème euh d'inadéquation entre les
exigences des employeurs et puis aussi
les exigences des salariés euh on va
essayer de s'en rendre compte sur le
terrain il se trouve qu' un un salon de
l'emploi qui s'appelle Paris emploi
c'est à Paris justement juste à côté de
l'Assemblée nationale place de la
Concorde c'est Clément Perro et Philippe
lecro qui s'y sont rendus
reportage sous ce grand barnome blanc on
recrute ou du moins on essaie au salon
pour l'emploi de Paris 400 entreprises
recruteuses ont installé leur stand dans
les secteurs sous tension les employux
ur sont aux aget c'est le cas dans
l'industrie cette entreprise de
maintenance dans l'aéronautique a une
vingtaine d'offres à
proposer ce poste est en cours de
recherche nous avons ce poste qui est
ouvert sur Paris est-ce que je peux vous
transmettre mon CV mais avec grand
plaisir je vous Enie plisir sachant
qu'il est en anglais c'est parfait c'est
parfait pense elle tombe vraiment dans
un timing parfait où les recherches sont
en cours sur ce poste et
elle pourrait demain être être notre
futur collaboratrice mais est-ce que
c'est un poste où réellement vous avez
des difficultés à recruter ce poste là
non pas réellement et c'est là tout le
problème en une demi-journée
l'entreprise a recueilli une vingtaine
de CV ils correspondent à certaines
offres mais pas à celles où les manques
sont les plus critiques on parle
beaucoup des ingénieurs aéronautiques on
parle beaucoup de Bac + 5 de niveau de
Master alors qu'en réalité nos besoins
sont vraiment plutôt basé sur des bacs
aéronautiques des des des profils plus
techniques qui ne vont pas nécessiter
beau beaucoup d'années d'étude et qui
sont pourtant pour nous les ressources
clés de demain parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est grâce au mécaniciens que les
pilotes volent les entreprises ne sont
pas les seuls à avoir des stands
certains territoires viennent aussi se
vendre c'est le cas de l'Indre dans ce
département où le taux de chômage est
bas plus de 3000 offres d'emploi sont à
pourvoir encore faut-il convaincre de
venir s'y installer c'est assez
compliqué il y a beaucoup de frein
beaucoup d'inquiétude le fait de devoir
quitter un un élément de confort une
région à la quel on peut être plus ou
moins attaché il a presque je vais pas
parler d'accompagnement psychologique
mais en tout cas on est là pour rassurer
manque de formation de mobilité à
l'heure où le chômage repart à la hausse
ce salon illustre bien les difficultés
rencontrées sur le marché du travail
français un candidat souvent a un projet
de vie a une idée en tête un métier
qu'il aimerait faire et parfois bah ça
correspond pas au aux offres proposé aux
attentes du marché aux attentes des
employeurs et parfois bah c'est c'est
difficile parce qu'en réalité c'est de
monde ne se parle pas ne se rencontre
pas le chômage une équation complexe
revenue au premier plan du débat public
il est bien fait ce reportage parce
qu'il montre exactement la difficulté
l'absence de rencontre entre ce
qu'attendent les employeurs là où ils
ont des besoins et puis les les
exigences les attentes aussi légitimes
des salariés qu'est-ce qu'on fait très
concrètement est-ce que c'est par le
chômage des seniors qu'on répond à ce
genre de problème d'inadéquation c'est
d'abord par la création d'emploi
il y a pas de miracle pour aller au 5 %
de plein emploi il faut créer entre 1
million et 1 million et demi d'emplois
là vous êtes d'accord c'est d'abord ça
qu'il faut faire c'est d'abord ça qu'il
faut faire je donne deux exemples très
concrets de comment on se bat pour créer
des emplois je vous parle un de la
mesure jeunes entreprises innovantes que
j'ai porté depuis plusieurs mois dans un
rapport que j'ai remis au gouvernement
qui a été intégré au projet de loi de
finance 2024 2028 cette mesure elle va
aider au financement des jeunes
entreprises no vantes c'est 50000 à 100
000 emplois créés dans les prochaines
années très concret deuxième exemple le
président de la République où est-ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui il est à chartre
pour inaugurer un méga investissement
d'un laboratoire danois novo nodisk qui
va investir 2 milliards d'euros à
chartre en France et créer 500 emplois
dans le cadre du programme ch France
qu'a lancé le président de la République
et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on est le
premier pays en Europe pour attirer les
investissements étrangers nous par des
emplois d'avenir si dire
chent V qu' a des GIs mais y a des
besoins il y a des besoins aujourd'hui
sur du travail peu qualifieré c'est ça
il faut le dire pourquoi on ne veut pas
ces emplois là est-ce qu'on est
suffisamment foré qui veut répondre
attendez pas tout le monde monsieur
Picon ait trouvver puis je fais circuler
c'est un c'est un sujet l'adéquation de
la formation des des jeunesou moins
jeunes changer de transition
professionnelle à un moment à un moment
de sa vie tout ça sont des freins
qui qu'il faut débloquer alors il y a ce
qu'on appelle les freins périphériques à
l'emploi il y a des gens qui
accepteraient un job qui leur est
proposé ils peuvent pas parce que il y a
pas de garde d'enfant il y a des
difficultés de logement il y a des
difficultés de mobilité c'est ce qu'on
appelle les freins périphériques à
l'emploi donc tout ça il faut travailler
là-dessus et les collectivités locales
on avait un représentant dans ce film
elles ont un rôle à jouer considér sur
la formation professionnelle les lycées
pro est-ce qu'on a changé de culture
parce que ça par rapport aux Allemands
on on revient de loin hein
je personne mais l'éducation nationale
depuis des années nous déverse des
gamins qui arrive complètement à à des
kilomètres de l'employabilité juste un
chiffre les gens qui passent par
l'apprentissage que ce soit dans les
dans les les préparations de cap de beep
de bac pro ou d'études supérieures
plus de 70 % des gens qui sortent d'un
contrat d'apprentissage trouvent
derrière un emploi et dans certaines
filières c'est plus de 80 %. on a on a
donc bien un problème dans notre pays de
d'adéquation de la formation avec les
besoins des entreprises mais pendant des
années les entreprises elles avaient pas
le droit de franchir le pas de l'école
comme si c'était le diable qui allait
entrer et parler aux enfants vous
trouvez que ça change un peu un petit
peu mais pas ass V pour les trouvver sur
la le problème de l'inadéquation voilà
mais je je veux bien je veux quand même
qu'on sache qu'il y a deux sujets
différents il y a celui du chômage et ça
a été dit pour répondre au chômage c'est
la création d'emploi il y a un autre
sujet qui est sur ces 360000 emplois
vacan dont un certain nombre de métiers
qu'on appelle en ttention et où il y a
des difficultés de trouver un certain
nombre de salariés bon vous parlez du
logement bon effectivement il y a une
question de logement accessible
notamment donc ça veut dire peut-être
qu'il faudrait plafonner par exemple les
loyers pour que les gens et bien
puissent avoir accè certaines villes le
font hein déjà donc voilà je je dis
c'est toute une série de mesures à mener
que nous on défend le plafonnement des
loyers deuxièmement les services publics
pourquoi les gens ont du mal à de plus
en plus à à déménager dans l'espace
rural ben parce que notamment il y a de
moins en moins de services publics
accessibles de postes accessibles et
cetera donc ça veut dire un plan massif
contrairement à ce que fait le
gouvernement d'établissement de services
publics un peu partout en France de
redonner les moyens aux hôpitaux publics
et à l'école publique parce que moi ce
que je vis en scène saint-n c'est un
manque mais absolument criant désastreux
de de moyens dans l'école publique
d'instituteurs mais pas seulement de
d'aesh de de tout ce personnel
d'assistante sociale et cetera qui donc
en mettant le paquet en relançant les
services publics vous pensez que malgré
les déficits on a standard qui nous
regarde et qui va noter la France en
début de semaine malgré des déficits
dans le rouge une dette colossale il
faut continuer à dépenser pour relancer
l'économ mais vous savez que nous ne
sommes pas des dangereux dépensiers nous
pensons que il y a de l'argent à les
chercher par la fiscalité notamment sur
les des très gros patrimoinees nous
demandons une taxation des super profits
par exemple pour justement pouvoir
financer notamment l'école publique et
et Monsieur Bruno Le Maire le ministre
de l'Économie dit notre modèle social et
ben ce qui aujourd'hui fait une des
richesses de la France c'est en tout cas
qui le faisait c'était une école
publique de qualité qui malheureusement
est en train pour moi de se dégrader à
vitesse grandv alors ça c'est l'économie
on tire un fil et puis c'est l'ensemble
de l'économie qui arrive je vous propose
quand même qu'on arrive à notre sujet
cette question du chômage est-ce que
c'est hypocrite le système aujourd'hui
est-ce que la durée d'indemnisation des
plus de 55 ans 27 mois c'est une manière
de mettre gentiment dehors le senior la
personne un peu plus âgée vraiment c'est
505 ans c'est pas très âgé par rapport à
à celui qui est perçu comme plus
dynamique et tranquillement hop on fait
la jonction jusqu'à la retraite est-ce
que c'est vraiment comme ça qu'on va
lutter contre le chômage alors vous
allez me détester mais je voudrais
réagir sur le filet de l'adéquation mais
après je répondrai à votre question
parce que évidemment l'adéquation c'est
très important et faut surtout pas dire
que c'est la faute des français surtout
pas c'est que le système est mal
organisé s'il y a pas une bonne
adéquation donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait un
c'est le développement de
l'apprentissage parce que quand on est
apprenti on trouve beaucoup plus
facilement un boulot on en a parlé voilà
et mais on est passé de 200000 à 1
million d'apprentis par an c'est majeur
dans la capacité à à faire cette
adéquation deuxième élément c'est les
nouvelles formations vers les emplois
qui embauche c'est 400000 professionnels
des du numérique qui vont être formés
dans les prochaines années et puis pour
mettre tout ça en adéquation il on a
créé France travail c'est important on
vient de le voter à l'Assemblée
nationale pour qui remplace pour
l'emploi pour organiser mieux cette
adéquation au niveau central et avec les
collectivités territoriales est-ce que
le système actuel incite les seigors je
vais parler franis Gérold je vous
redonner la parole après à partir plus
tôt la fameuse rupture conventionnelle
qui fait qu'elle est à 62 ans vous avez
2 an vous êtes à 2 ans de la retraite
déjà le taux d'emploi entre 60 et 64 il
est 10 points de plus que entre 55 et et
60 donc il y a vraiment un sujet en
France sur le chômage des seniors est-ce
que le système est fait de telle manière
que tout le monde y trouve son compte le
seior qui qui va faire ses ses 4 ans 2
ans chômage et puis ensuite la retraite
et le et l'employeur qui veut du du plus
jeune voilà est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a
un vrai sujet là qu'il faut changer oui
mais c'est pas facile fa ça fait des
années qu'on parle de ce problème làà du
fait que les Seigneur sont poussés de
leur entreprise souvent d'ailleurs des
grandes entreprises donc c'est très
difficile de donner des responsabilités
de dire c'est de la faute du chômeur ou
du Seigneur qui se fait virer
effectivement enfin qui se fait pousser
vers la sortie ou que c'est de la faute
de l'employeur franchement c'est une
question de culture à mon avis aussi de
comment bah en tout cas ce qu'on observe
empiriquement c'est qu'effectivement il
y a une spécificité française de ce côté
ce côté-là alors après c'était lié aussi
pour pourquoi comment ça s'explique en
Allemagne par exemple on travaille plus
plus longtemps dans l'entreprise on
reste bah je pense qu'effectivement il y
a une façon de voir aussi la carrière de
voir il y a il y a un côté aussi on
quand quand on est jeune en France c'est
très difficile et puis après une fois
qu'on a obtenu le CDI ou une fois qu'on
a une position confortable dans une
entreprise voilà on est on estime que
c'est normal qu'on soit protégé et
cetera donc du coup les entreprenes les
les entreprises à l'inverse elles
essayent de trouver des échappatoir mais
pour vous les durées d'indemnisation euh
ne sont pas justifié qu'elles soi
différente entre les seniors 27 mois et
les va avoir c'est que en fait c'est
chez les seniors qui ne qui sont
chômeurs qu'on voit la durée de au
chômage la plus longue un un seigneur
sur deux est un chômeur de longue durée
en fait et donc ça va être très très
difficile de dire euh enfin voilà de de
de dire on met spécifiquement le coup de
projecteur sur eux parce que vraiment
c'est là où on a l'impression que que la
responsabilité est largement partagée je
vous ai pas oublié Paul midi je reviens
vers vous Michel Pic déjà on se dit ça
va mettre encore pas mal de gens dans la
rue ça va pas être facile ass
ê oui je suis employeur je représente
des petites entreprises la plupart moins
de 20 salariés et franchement dans ces
entreprises là lorsqu'un seior s'en va à
l'âge de la retraite ben c'est c'est un
problème c'est un sujet parce qu'il a la
compétence il a le savoir il a la
relation client il a plein de choses
vous l'avez vu déjà dans les entreprises
c'est fréquent quê dans les petites
entreprises mais j'entends madame que
les grands groupes group dans les grands
groupes les plans ce qu'on a appelé les
préretraites unédiqu où les les grosses
boîtes les grosses entreprises ont
dégagé des courortes de cadres qui leur
coûtaient trop cher pour aller chercher
des cadres plus jeunes qui leur
coûteraient moins cher ça a été une
pratique pendant des années les
partenaires sociaux qui qui qui gèrent
l'Unedic aujourd'hui ont dit c'est
terminé mdeef compris sauf que ce que
propose Bruno Le Maire lu n dit que les
partenaires n'en veulent pas non mais
monsieur le ministre Bruno Le Maire dit
il faut aller plus bas il y a moins d'un
an le gouvernement a fait une réforme
des retraites puisque les partenaires le
gouvernement avait repris la main sur la
gestion de l'assurance chômage et et le
gouvernement est passé de 36 à 27 mois
il y a pas il y a moins d'un an que
cette cette réforme a été mise en œuvre
on est passé de 36 pour les seigiors à
27 mois et pour les nonseiors on est
passé de 24 à 18 est-ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin peut-être en tout cas c'est un
débat c'est une discussion sembl être
favorable personnellement à titre
personnel je suis favorable oui à une
chose d'abord c'est que les jeunes
travaille et que ça le premier problème
oui c'est le premier
problème VI je suis pas sûr qu'à 55 ans
on soit
vieux c'est VI chage des jeunes la
priorité c'est le chômage des jeunes et
et bien sûr les seiors aussi mais on a
des des propositions à pouvoir aurz les
trouver sur la proposition de Bruno Le
Maire bah déjà ça a été dit il y a une
réforme des retraites il y a 6 mois qui
d'près l' FCE d'ailleurs et d'autres
études économiques et bien va plonger
tout un tas de de seniors justement dans
le chômage quoi et dans le chômage parce
qu'en fait en repoussant de 62 à 64 ans
l'âge de départ à la retraite bah il y a
tout un tout un voilà des beaucoup
beaucoup de de salariés qui de fait vont
se retrouver au chômage ah bon parce que
normalement jonger l'âge de départ ça
maintient normalement les gens plus
longts dans l'ement c'estd que vous
repoussez à 64 ans donc les gens qui
était au chômage si vous voulez par
exemple à 61 ans bah voilà ch ils sont
au chômage plus longtemps et par
ailleurs c'est aussi ça a été montré par
l' Cece et d'autres mais vous reviendrez
dessus
François que par ailleurs bah ça a aussi
un effet de de mettre plus de seniors
sur le sur le marché du travail si vous
voulez et d'enlever aussi de l'emploi
aux jeunes bon autre élément je voudrais
dire que cette histoire de encore
diminuer la durée d'indemnisation des
seniors c'est encore un coup coup de
rabau des droits des chômeurs et depuis
2021 il y a eu plusieurs décisions qui
font que le les les indemnités chômage
la durée d'indemnisation tout ça est
considérablement diminuée pour les
chômeurs et il y a tout un pan des
chômeurs qui se retrouvent dans une
pauvreté beaucoup plus grande c'est le
résultat du dernier rapport de du
Secours Catholique qui montre que
notamment et bien il y a il y a un très
grand nombre et de plus en plus de de de
de chômeurs longue durée par exemple qui
tombent dans une pauvreté absolue du
fait notamment de
ces pris par le gouvernement il y a eu
des des milliards d'économies faites sur
le dos des chômeurs et ça en matière de
arguments contre sont très clairs et
précis qu'est-ce que vous répondez et
c'est un débat qui s'achève donc
rapidementut pas oublier la situation de
notre pays et se cacher derrière son
petit doigt il y a de la discrimination
face à l'âge d' notre pays antiieux
antisior pour le dire un peu plus
poliment mais c'est la même chose qui
est inacceptable et on s'est accommodé
dans les 30 dernières années anné
finalement cette forme de discrimination
et on
réduisantation dans le système dans
notre système dans nos règles on a
finalement accepté que c'était normal
que des personnes en fin de carrière
c'était pas très grave si elles étaient
au chômage puisque la retraite arrivait
derrière et donc on a
facilité cet état de fête qui est
d'ailleurs comme l'a dit très bien
monsieur très peu utilisé par les
petites entreprises qui ont besoin de
leur Seigneur utilisé par les grands
groupes quand ils font des plans sociaux
et bien cet état de faê il est in acable
pour nous et donc on veut que les règles
soient alignées entre les seigors et les
autres parce queil y a pas de raison de
donner des incitations aux grandes il
ira au bout c'est un ballon d'ESS juste
pour savoir parce que c'est un pe
explosif oh là une proposition on en est
pas encore là B on s'arrête là vous
reviendrez he si c'est sur la table des
partenaires sociaux ou si le
gouvernement reprend la main et et en
fait même un retour au Parlement merci
beaucoup on s'arrête là merci d'être
venu débattre sur ce plateau dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties pr ns
affranchi ce soir s'interroge sur le
Black Friday après la diffusion d'un
clip de l'Adème appelant à son boycott
Pierre-Henry tavoyot nous éclaire à une
semaine de la COP 28 sur les différentes
familles de l'écologie et puis de quoi
nous parlez-vous dans Bourbon Express ce
soir Marco Marco Pomier et bien ce soir
je m'intéresse à l'article 4 bis celui
qui bloque le projet de loi immigration
à l'Assemblée le totem du projet de loi
en effet à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va accueillir Patrick Klugman
il est l'avocat des familles d'otage
franco-israélien détenu par le Hamas à
Gaza des familles dans l'angoisse totale
et qui retiennent leur souffle alors
qu'Israël a reçu une première liste
d'otage libéré dès demain Patrick lugman
nous rejoint juste après son portrait
signé Elsa Mondin
Gava si on vous invite Patrick Klugman
c'est parce que le monde retient son
souffle un accord a été trouvé pour
libérer 50 otages des mains du Hamas
mais leur libération se fera au
comptegoutte un premier groupe de 13
femmes et enfants demain une attente
insupportable vous représentez quatre
familles d'otage franco-israélien vous
comprenez qu'on est dans un principe de
loterie insoutenable de loterie humaine
sur ce premier groupe de 50 sur un total
de 240 dont nous ne savons pas qui est
vivant et qui est mort et sur ce total
de 240 vous avez des nourrissons vous
avez des personnes âgées vous avez
personnes particulièrement vulnérabl
Patrick lugman vous êtes avocat conseil
du CRIF et de SOS raciste
coordinateur du Comité freem pour la
libération des otages dans votre
carrière vous avez défendu des proches
de victimes d'attentat ceux de l'école
auzaratora de Toulouse ou encore de
l'hypercacher mais aussi la famille de
Guil Chalit ce soldat franco-israélien
capturé par le Hamas en 2006 est libéré
5 ans plus tard en échange de plus de
1000 prisonniers
palestiniens il y a quelques jours au
nom des familles que vous repr présenté
vous avez déposé plainte devant la
justice française pour enlèvement et
séquestration en relation avec une
entreprise
terroriste la question des otages au
cœur de la guerre entre Israël et le
Hamas 240 personnes ont été kidnappé un
accord a finalement été conclu après de
longues négociations et l'intermédiaire
du Qatar en contrepartie de la
libération de 50 Otages une trêve
humanitaire de 4 jours et la libération
de 150 prisonniers palestiniens alors
que demain 13 femmes et enfants seront
libérés ce soir Patrick lugman nous
avons une
question les familles que vous
représentez vont-elles retrouver enfin
leurs
proches bonsoir Patrick Klugman B merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir on a
beaucoup de questions à vous poser on va
commencer par les voir ses visages si
vous le voulez bien des h otages
français détenus par le Hamas je je dis
détenu parce que mis à part Mia Chem en
bas à droite c'est cette jeune femme aux
yeux bleus dont on a eu une preuve de
vie tout ce que l'on peut dire ce soir
c'est que ces h figurent parmi les 240
disparus je vais donner leur nom il la
famille
yalomi le père OAD le fils etan la
famille Calderon que vous défendez offer
le père Sare la fille et R le fils et
puis deux hommes ela Toledano Orion
Hernandez radou et enfin MiEV kidna lors
de la rêve partie est-ce que ce soir
Patrick Klugman vous savez si parmi ses
visages et on pense évidemment aux
enfants aux jeunes femmes certains
seront libérés demain ou dans les 3 qu
jours qui viennent je n'en sais rien je
n'en sait rien et nous n'en savons
rien voilà c'est une nous sommes en face
d'une loterie humaine il y a pas pire je
crois c'est une roulette russe où on
dispose de la liberté de ces personne
dont nous dont nous ne savons toujours
pas comme vous le disiez fort justement
si elles sont vivantes ou pas comment
comment c dernires he Dansel é sontell
les familles c'est vous imaginez que les
familles des 240 sont très soudé depuis
le 7 octobre et certains vont retrouver
leurs proches demain dans les jours
suivants pas tous il y en a certains qui
savent que leurs proches sont morts qu'
l'ont appris en tout cas depuis le 7
octobre il y en a qui vont l'apprendre
donc tout le monde sait que on ne
retrouvera pas tout le monde parmi les
240 et pourtant ils ont décidé de rester
soudés c'est pourquoi moi bien sûr je ne
représente en France que ceux qui m'ont
confier un mandat qui sont
franco-israéliens mais c'est c'est un un
ensemble et c'est il y a deux manières
de prendre cette cette cette histoire
soit on parle de ces 240 personnes et on
parlera aussi des 1200 autres qui ont
été massacrés ça on parlera de 1 + 1 + 1
et je crois continuer comme ça longtemps
euh voilà il c'est pas une affaire de
nationalité c'est pas une affaire de
voilà c'est une affaire de principe
c'est une affaire d'être humain c'est
une affaire de gens qui sont faut
comprendre que déjà dans ces famillesl
dans toutes ces familles là quasiment il
n'y a pas des otages il y a des otages
et très souvent des
victimes la famille Calderon par exemple
la grand-mère Carmel Dane est morte le
jour de ses 80 ans on a appris sa mort
le jour de ses 800 ans il a il y a eu
d'autres qui sont sont morts le kibut
nose on a reçu d'ailleurs une famille en
France de cette famille Calderon vous
leur parlez comment on fait pour tenir
dans cette épreuve là comment
vivent-elles cette attente les les
familles sont d'une combativité
impressionnant ils sont au combat ils
sont au combat ils sont mobilisés ils
sont groupés ils sont unis ils sont
fraternels c'est franchement on a là
face à face les deux extrêmes de
l'humanité vous avez un groupe je ne
sais même pas ce qu'ils ont dans la tête
pour avoir commis ce qu'ils ont fait
pour en plus l'avoir capteré et diffuser
et pour faut faut quand même
avoir je ne sais pas comment je trouve
pas le mot pour prendre un bébé et
l'emmener ou le découper et le filmer et
de l'autre côté vous avez cette humanité
merveilleuse cette humanité merveilleuse
qui continue à croire en la vie qui
continue d'espérer qui n' abdiqué aucun
des Prin p qui nous font tenir et qui
nous donne à nous qui les conseillons
les assistons des leçons d'espoir et de
vie êre binational dans ce cas-là c'est
un atout oui les rumeurs laissent
entendre que les B nationaux seraient
prioritaires sur cette priorité sur ce
cette loterie je veux pas m'avancer mais
rationnellement on aurait tendance à
dire que bien sûr
être binational est un avantage dans la
mesure où nous savons que pour
ces ravisseurs ces terroristes j'ai pas
envie de dire d'autres mots euh être
israélien est une infamie donc on va
dire que l'infamie est peut-être un
petit peu atténuée si c'est possible
quand on est français et israélien quand
on est américain et israélien en fait ce
qui est très étonnant c'est qu'on
connaît déjà beaucoup de choses sur ces
ces accords en général on sait rien
jusqu'aux libération et là très
étonnamment on on communique beaucoup
communiqueent d'ailleurs au risque d'un
grand bazar et d'une grande
désorganisation la télévision
israélienne a commencé à donner de nom
finalement ils se sont rétractés et
cetera donc c'est très difficile
j'imagine pour les familles de tenir
dans un tel contexte comment se passe la
communication avec les porte-paroles du
gouvernement israélien qui donne les
noms comment ça se passe au dernier
moment est-ce que les familles concernés
sont déjà au courant toute la mécanique
n'est pas connue en tout cas
l'information la plus récente c'est le
premier ministre israélien netanahou qui
l'a donné sur Twitter par un tweet où il
dit effectivement qu'une liste a été
donnée par l'armée aux familles donc la
la communication est effectivement très
transparente très officielle je crois
que dans la situation dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons qui est assez complexe
inédite la publicité ça permet de figer
les choses et de prendre des des
garanties sur un accord avec des des
protagonistes ça met la pression sur la
des protagonistes qui ne se parlent pas
directement expliquez-nous ça bah il y a
il y a le parle gouvernement israélien
ne parle pas évidemment au
il y a des des médiateurs il y a des
puissances médiatrices la France en est
une les États-Unis en font une autre il
y en a d'autres qui parlent au au Qatar
les Israéliens par avec le Qatar on sait
que derrière le Qatar a des
interlocuteurs du Hamas sur place sa que
l'Égypte joue un rôle immense y compris
pour l'accès et on sait que le CCR est
impliqué alors justement parlons-en C
c'est le feu à partir de demain matin
libération d'un premier groupe de civil
à 15h française c'est ça échange d'un
certain nombre de prisonniers
palestiniens on connait pas le nombre
exact à ce jour pour la journée de de
demain il y aura aussi l'ouverture d'un
convoi humanitaire ça c'est très
important c'est le CICR donc la croix-
rouge qui devrait apporter les soins
médicaux nécessaires est-ce qu'on peut
faire confiance au Hamas de laisser ces
ONG faire leur travail humanitaire
évidemment qu'on ne peut pas faire
confiance au Hamas c'est le principe
d'une organisation qui s'est donné pour
but de ne respecter aucune règle aucune
roi aucune loi et le moment pas même ni
sa propre charte ni la charia qui
proclame dedans donc évidemment qu'on ne
peut pas avoir confiance ça va être du
day by day du jour après jour et on
verra ce qui se passe et et moi j'ai les
plus grandes craintes sur cet accord qui
en plus est un gûoutte à goutte vous
savez on est face au
supplice su le supplice dans le supplice
c'est c'est il y a aucune euphorie nulle
part il y a aucune il y a aucun espoir
il il y a rien là là c'est la l'horreur
maximale l'horreur maximale vous avez
représenté le soldat franco-israélien
Gilad Chalit détenu galement par le
Hamas qui a été libéré à l'époque contre
1000 prisonniers palestiniens parmi
lesquels devaient figurer les
terroristes du massacre du 7 octobre
aujourd'hui en tout cas les principaux
instigateurs on ét instigateurs libérés
à ce moment-là ont été libérés et font
enfin ceux qui ont conçu l'attaque du 7
octobre celui euh qui a conçuattaque du
7 octobre et a été libéré par l'accord
de de Gilat Chalit mais c'était le
prixay c'estdisraël a libéré celui qui
allait commettre les assassinats de et
captations d'otage un contre 1000
c'était il y a plusieurs années
aujourd'hui c'est un pour trois le
rapport de force a complètement changé
c'est la le signe que le hamass est
acculé c'est euh écoutez le Hamas est je
ne sais pas si est acculé en tout cas il
est encore en état de détenir et d'avoir
de droit de vie ou de mort sur des
personnes qu'il retient donc il n'est
pas encore complètement acculé son sa
tête pensante au Qatar n'est toujours
pas hors d'état de nuire donc non on
doit on doit constater que ils sont
encore en état de de de de faire ces
négociations atroces ce ce marché de
chair humaine et et voilà et on n' pas
mieux à à faire que de que de S qu'il
puisse être libéré je voudrais vous
faire entendre les mots très forts d'un
animateur il s'agit d'Arthur sur les
ondes de France interre ce
matin il a il a raison Patrick lman déjà
il il dit des choses qui sont qui sont
justes mais je crois que tous les enfin
il y a eu quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de de retentissement sur ces 240 otages
en France dans les médias dans les
médias français d'ailleurs hein les
députés certains d'entre eux ont décidé
de les parraener et d'afficher leur
portrait beaucoup beaucoup d'initiativ
donc je je là-dessus je je ne re homage
rejo pas l'hommage hommage aux 40
français
franco-israéliens qui ont été exécutés
dans les massacres du Hamas est-ce qu'il
tarde à venir ou pas à vos yeux euh il
tard il tarde à venir mais on ne sait
pas encore qui est vivant et qui est
mort donc il y a eu aucun hommage nulle
part qui a été rendu parce que on sait
qu'il y a des morts on en découvre
encore jour après jour vous savez
pourquoi on on découvre parce que on a
du mal à identifier des restes de
cadavres du 7 octobre encore aujourd'hui
on n' pas fini ce travail là et puis il
y a cette ceux dont on ne sait pas s'il
sont autâ vivants ou mort il est
impossible en l'état de rendre hommage à
qui que ce soit on ne sait pas qui est
vivant et qui est Mor et on espère
encore qu'il y ait le plus de vivants
possible parmi ces 2ot rapidement parce
que nos chroniqueurs nous attendent ils
vont vous faire réagir parlez-nous de la
plainte en justice que vous avez déposé
contre le Hamas pour enlèvement et
séquestration il y a la justice
française il y a aussi un mandat d'arrêt
devant la Cour pénale internationale à
La Haie un jour vous pensez vraiment que
que ces procès vont pouvoir avoir lieu
le droit devra avoir le dernier mot mais
là nous ne sommes pas dans une séquence
judiciaire même si vous avez remarqué
que la Cour pénal international commence
à se saisir des questions des conflits
en cours c'était le cas en Ukraine c'est
maintenant le cas avec ce qu' se passe à
Gaza et essae de dire du droit pendant
une guerre ou un conflit avec des mots
qui sont intéressants d'ailleurs donc
mais c'est pas encore le bon moment
c'est pas encore le moment mais c'est
déjà le moment de saisir la justice
puisque toutes ces personnes sont des
justiciables sont des justiciaables pour
les franco-israens de la justice
française sont des justiciables de
toutes les justices qui sont concernés
compris d'ailleurs la justice
israélienne et vous savez il n'y a que
avec le ramas que la justice n'existe
pas et que le droit n'existe pas mais le
droit le droit merci infiniment merci
Patrick gugman d'avoir répondu à nos
questions vous allez réagir au partiprix
de nos affranchis qu'on accueille tout
de suite et les voilà le duo du jeudi
ilel Goos de France interre Pierre-Henri
tavoyot pour son Biget philo
installez-vous on commence par Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
c'est Marco Pomier bonsoir Marco qui
nous la raconte bonsoir Myriam ce soir
je vous raconte l'histoire d'un article
qui continue de cristalliser les tension
sur le projet de loi les débats celui
qui crée un titre de séjour pour les
travailleurs en papier dans les métiers
en tension initialement c'était
l'article 3 du texte du Gouvernement une
ligne rouge pour les républicains
article qui a donc été supprimé par la
droite Sénat sénatoriale pardon et
remplacé par un autre article plus
restrictif le 4 bis cet article il
prévoit toujours la régularisation des
travailleurs étrangers dans les métiers
en pénurie de main-dœuvre mais les
conditions d'éligibilité sont durci et
surtout les sénateurs ont réintroduit le
principe d'une régularisation à
l'appréciation du préfet c'est-à-dire
dire au cas par cas à titre exceptionnel
et c'est cette réécriture qui ne passe
pas à l'Assemblée oui c'est le MO qu'on
puisse dire he mais vous le savez la
politique Myriam c'est aussi l'art du
compromis alors Floriant bouier député
de la majorité et rapporteur général du
texte à l'Assemblée tente de trouver une
troisième voix une voix de passage via
un amendement je proposerai à à notre
commission une solution qui ne soit ni
le droit automatique général et absolu
qui pose une série de difficultés
réelles ni le pouvoir discrétionnaire du
préfet tel que le Sénat pu le prévoir
bon en clair on garde les conditions
d'éligibilité durcies par le Sénat pour
obtenir le titre de séjour en revanche
terminer le pouvoir discrétionnaire du
préfet il devra régulariser quelques
motifs de refus quand même deux exemples
hein une menace à l'ordre public ou le
non respect des valeurs de la République
le dispositif de régularisation serait
limité dans le temps jusqu'au 31
décembre 2026 objectif de cet amendement
convaincre l'aile gauche de la macronie
qui réclame haut et fort depuis depuis
plusieurs semaines cette régularisation
convaincre aussi la droite à l'Assemblée
alors est-ce que ça marche bah c'est mal
parti ça semble même mission impossible
cet article 4 bis réécrit ou pas reste
une mesure de régularisation et ça c'est
inacceptable pour le rassemblement
national inacceptable aussi pour les
républicains de l'assemblée qui au
passage désavouent les républicains du
Sénat écoutez nous sommes opposés à
toute mesure de
régularisation voilà c'est très clair
sur ce point comme je suis pas
de l'année c'est pas parce qu'on me dit
l'article 3 s'appelle maintenant article
4 bis que je vais le voter je sais que
c'est le même en réalité en l'état nous
n'avons qu'une raison de voter ce texte
voilà Marine Le Pen qui durcit le ton
droite et extrême droite qui redoute
l'appel d'air pour l'immigration
irrégulière tout cela myiam sera débattu
dès lundi en commission des lois on l'a
appris en fin de journée quelques 15500
amendements ont été déposés à ce stade
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi
immigration 261 pour la majorité plus de
1300 pour l'opposition voilà pour le
détail ouais quelle bataille
parlementaire en perspective qui sera
diffusée en intégralité en direct sur
LCP on enchaîne avec vous psychodrame
autour d'un spot télé jugé décroissant
le gouvernement peut-il demander au
français de moins consomm avant Noël
alors pour bien comprendre de quoi on
parle regardez c'est l'un des qure spots
diffusés par l'ADEM l'agence de la
transition écologique et diffusé depuis
le 14
novembre vous prendriez leel vous hnê ou
aucun des deux mais c'est à moins 70 %
franchement pour un vendeur vous êtes
pas ah non pas du tout moi je suis
dévendeur et je vous conseille le mo-s
100 %. il y a moins 100 % bah oui le
vôtre il est très
bien je peux hésitez pas si vous avez
besoin que je vous déconseille d'autres
achats ça soulagera les ressources de la
planète e et vos placards
h voilà efficace le vendeur antigaspie
hein celui qui dévend et qui vous
conseille d'emprunter ou de recycler
avouez que c'est original c'est un spot
qui a été validé par le ministère de la
transition écolog logique qui exaspère
ce spot les professionnels du commerce
pour eux c'est stigmatisant la CPME la
la Confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprise dit que c'est une gifle pour
les commerçants dans un moment où ils
souffrent de l'inflation et de d'une
activité au ralenti colère aussi des
industriels du textile et tout ça toute
cette colère est remontée jusqu'à Bercy
chez Bruno Le Maire qui fustige une
campagne maladroite et culpabilisante à
tel point qu'à Matignon on aimerait
maintenant stopper la diffusion des
spots alors pour vous il pose probl
c'est spot ou pas ce qui est
problématique c'est l'incohérence il y a
de jours et vous en parliez dans le
débat tout à l'heure le président a dit
aux acteurs économiques réveillez-vous
parce que le plein emploi c'est encore
loin et dans le même temps le
gouvernement diffuse ses spots antionau
cacophonie au gouvernement le ministre
de la transition écologique Christophe
béu lui dit qu'il continuera à diffuser
ses spots pour moi bien plus qu'un quak
on est vraiment là dans une
contradiction majeure qui signe les
contradictions de notre époque
c'est-à-dire c'estàd dire que à un
moment donné il faut prendre ses
responsabilités si le Black Friday est
une débauche de surconsommation qui
produit du CO2 est-ce qu'il y a pas
besoin en face d'un contre-discours bah
c'est ce que fait la dem elle est dans
son rôle on achète en moyenne 30 % de
plus de vêtements qu'il y a 10 ans 30 %
de plus est-ce que c'est ça la sobriété
sur la quantité de pub télé qui incite à
consommer les spots de laadem en
représentent 0,2 % et on s'offusque
qu'un message de responsabilisation
Vienne fâcher l'industrie du textile je
pense qu'on touche du doigt la les
limites de l'écologie à la française non
punitive telle qu'Emmanuel Macron la
revendique ne jamais culpabiliser
toujours incité parler recyclages mais
jamais toucher à la conso parce que
c'est un moteur fragile de la croissance
sauf que pour changer les comportements
ben il est pas interdit d'être plus
incisif de provoquer pour provoquer le
changement surtout quand l'État
maintenant subventionne la réparation de
vos appareils en panne ou de vos
chaussures usées un mini green Thursday
un min jeud ver avant l'orgie du Black
Friday est-ce que ça mérite une telle
panique au sommet de l'État non je crois
pas et si tout le monde surréagit au
moindre message qui gêne cette
transition écologique risque de finir en
chemin de croix et ben voilà ce que
j'appelle un beau parti prix voilà et
qui fait une parfaite transition avec
votre billet Pierre-Henri parce que vous
aussi vous voulez parler écologie on est
à une semaine exactement de coup d'envoi
de la COP 28 qui va se dérouler à Dubaï
et vous vouliez revenir sur les formes
contemporaines les les SEP familles de
écologie si on peut dire ouais les CIN
nuances de verre on pourrait dire 50
nuances de verre aujourd'hui l'opinion
publique est assez ralliée à l'écologie
et donc de ce point de vue là c'est pas
c'est plus un problème on voit dans dans
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion montre que
c'est la préoccupation principale de de
l'opinion publique après si tout le
monde est écolo personne ne l'est
exactement de la même manière et c'est
dans ces petites nuances qui
apparaissent que le débat est
intéressant alors est-ce qu'on peut s'y
retrouver dans dans cette diversité
alors là je me PL vraiment d'un point de
vue philosophique et non pas politique
c'est il y a deux grandes famille en
fait de d'écologie selon qu'on on prend
l'objectif principal est-ce qu'il s'agit
de protéger la maison de l'homme ou
est-ce qu'il s'agit de protéger la
nature pour elle-même le mot écologie
vient en grec ocos logos le le discours
sur la maison c'est comment on aménage
la maison donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'environnementalisme
l'environnementalisme c'est protéger la
nature parce qu'elle est l'environnement
de l'humain ça n'exclut pas un peu de
sobriété hein donc il faut c'est pas du
tout voilà simplement l'idée de ménager
d'aménager la nature d'en prendre soin
parce que c'est notre maison puis il y a
un deuxième courant qu'on appelle aux
États-Unis la Deep écology la Deep
écology c'est vraiment de considérer que
voilà la nature doit être protégée pour
elle-même parce qu'elle est presque
d'ailleurs un peu sacrée parce qu'elle
est divine Gaia et cette nature qu'on
doit protéger contre elle d'elle-même on
doit la protéger contre les hommes qui
sont effectivement dans cette tendance
de devenir comme maître et possesseur de
la nature donc on a d'un côté une
écologie anthropocentrée l'homme au
centre ou une épologie qui est un peu
antihumaniste et voilà avec des bons
arguments de deux côtés attention il y a
d'autres clivages possible dans cette
planète verte il y a un clivage qui
m'intéresse particulièrement qui est un
peu méconnu c'est est-ce que l'écologie
c'est une politique ou est-ce que c'est
une religion ou une spiritualité ce qui
met un peu la la puce à l'oreille de
cette idée c'est c'est la phrase fétiche
sauver la planète sauver la planète et
l'idée c'est si vous sauvez la planète
vous vous sauvez vous-même or ça c'est
un discours religieux et si on met ce
discours religieux en parallèle avec des
grands discours c'est vrai que pour un
Grec un philosophe grec de l'antiquité
c'est franchement ridicule sauver la
planète se sauver la nature parce que
pour un Grec la nature c'est ce qui ne
meurt pas tout croit tout naî tout croit
tout meurt il y a une seule chose qui ne
change pas c'est que tout change c'est
ça l'éternité donc pour un Grec sauver
la nature c'est franchement ridicule
pour un chrétien aussi parce que sauver
la nature bah sauver le monde il y en a
un qui en a le monopole c'est le
Salvator Mundi le Christ les autres
voilà ils doivent sauter donc d'une
certaine façon pardon je je paraphrase
saint paaul euh cet écologisme moderne
c'est un un scandale pour les chrétiens
et une folie pour les Grecs mais malgré
tout ce qu'il y a de profond c'est que
cette grille de lecture religieuse
permet de comprendre qu'il y a un
certain nombre de phénomènes par exemple
l'écoanxiété l'écoanxiété c'est c'est
l'angoisse en quelque sorte de ne pas
être à l'auteur de de la
mission le goût de l'Apocalypse il y a
un goût de l'Apocalypse quand même c'est
l'idée que la fin du monde est proche et
puis aussi le fanatisme il faut bien le
reconnaître c'est l'idée que je suis
seul dans à crier dans le déser et que
dans ce désert ben voilà il y a a y a
l'urgence climatique et ça engage des
choses donc oui à l'écologie mais
attention à l'écologisme voilà encore
une fois ne me faites pas dire ce que
j'ai pas dit l'écologie n'est pas que de
l'écologisme mais il y a une dimension
spirituelle qu'il faut aussi ne pas
négliger une réaction patriman penser
moi je suis pas très religieux mais il y
a quelque chose très joli dans la
tradition juive c'est quel est le rôle
d'évolu à l'homme après la création du
monde et cetera c'est la réparation du
monde et la réparation du monde ça fait
nîre le concept de responsabilité de
nous autres les les les humains et ce
qui nous amène brutalement à notre sujet
l'écologie peut-être pas une science
peut-être pas une religion mais en tout
cas elle doit devenir une politique des
politiques publiques parce que sinon
malheureusement il ne restera plus
grandchose de ce dont nous parlons et
c'est sûr que maintenant on peut plus
nier que l'activité de l'homme est
destructrice et pour la terre commune et
pour à la fin l'espè humaine elle-même
et donc voilà c'est l'heure de la une
responsabilitéique plutôt qu'une mission
ça bouleverse apparemment
l'ordonement J et même le pape François
a sa vision écologique aujourd'hui là où
date aussi il y a eu deux versions de
refait encore à l'automne un des plus
grands promoteurs de l'écologie
politique le PAP François ahà n'ouvrez
pas le débat c'est la fin c'est un
activiste deéc Merci à VOUS Patrick
lugman d'être passé je sais que vous
êtes extrêmement occupé bon courage pour
les jours qui viennent et nous espérons
évidemment que les otages
francoisraéliens seront seront sur les
listes à venir merci à vous les
affranchi Marco paupier prier à très
vite c'est la fin de cette émission pour
la voir ou la revoir la chaîne Youtube
d' LCP très belle soirée à
[Musique]
demain